oh and just like uh for no reason i'm
not gonna use this information to make
money at all when you're fighting do you
try to knock someone out or you try to
submit them or the fight just goes
wherever it goes
again not related to anything personally
just curious if uh just just out of
curiosity i probably just you've got
you've got to flow with it nick
you can't predict sorry
but
drop me a message before your next
[Music]
it says recording for sure
yeah the red lights on and the time's
going up so yeah when that red light
comes on that means it's official thank
god scary cats out of the dark baby what
is this our 17th ninth ninth close
almost ten almost ten oh yeah we almost
had the double digits almost nick says
he was gonna take mushrooms on number
10. i was just gonna bring it up i
didn't know you remember yeah
yeah hell yeah but don't you have to
take it a little bit before the episode
starts i think it'll take about a half
hour before yeah cause i was like
doesn't it it has to like kick in um
okay
yeah okay
maybe i'll just do it every 10 and i'll
just increase my dosage
because i am still afraid of bad trips
i'll i'll take a little bit of this
frequently uh
um
anybody who's not driving
why
just because i don't think you could you
don't want to drive almost you just
don't want to be everybody's driving
yeah huh yeah everybody you still want
to say on air that you're intoxicated
and driving true
i uber
well yeah he does i also uber you might
just be editing while yeah
it's like a four-hour trip yeah you know
colors and stuff screens get so bright
they're like impossible to like focus on
and [ __ ] even a tiny little bit huh if
you just take a little tiny bit uh
no you could probably still edit but i
just feel like you wouldn't i wouldn't
want to try it yeah you know what you
you should do you know um you should do
magic mine which i think uh he should
have some schneiderlin
mushrooms
instead of mushrooms
we should be tossing this bad boy back
to get this episode started because we
got echinacea or no
jack shore
[Laughter]
no
echinacea of course is one of the 12
natural ingredients is right
yes jack shore
is our undefeated ufc fighter friend
who's going to be zooming in later later
on yes uh
nick's got this he don't need the
website to help him out but i do like i
i like the screen record is screen
recorder going i'm sure it is yeah you
know what's up uh if you go to buy now
and actually enter in the promo code
dark and see the see the discount
applied yeah it does apply
we're not we're not enter flow state
yeah we're being real with you guys
you know we're not lying about that that
promo code
what let's see put it in there
put it in the air oh
you see that and that's something
there's a habit that's the monthly
subscription because if you're serious
about your magic mind you're going to
take it every day yeah yeah let's get
this okay let's get this episode started
baby
hell yeah
i want to take my little later but i'll
still take it on air just a little later
just a little later finish this thing
right okay uh keep track of chin yeah
cheers
cheers
cheers yeah let's keep track of chin
i'm already there
you know that one yeah i do
what was that noise
just the hottest jam on the planet magic
mime the hardest jingle you've ever
heard
about to make the whole day
wake up
[Laughter]
but then i'm like why would i do this
yeah
i need more i need more space really
because i feel like you dance for you
for you and that's what's so beautiful
about it i i if anybody who that night
of that corey feldman concert i went in
live when i was the last person that was
like the freest i've ever danced again
and like there was no one on the dance
floor but there was still a dj doing a
set so like i was pumping her up she was
bumping me up it was that was amazing
feeding off each other no shrooms no
shrooms no mushrooms that night just
weed uh weed that natural herb and
alcohol a little alcohol
anyone got any natural herb i do
you got that pen you know someone in
here always has that natural herb
oh that was bad
so that wasn't my fault no okay okay
cool you're fine are you gonna try it
again
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
nick you losing weight
oh black yeah you're right
i'm wearing black just a fresh haircut
but that's the nicest thing oh in a
haircut to me at the moment yeah fresh
haircut
that'll make me appear lighter because
my receding hairline
i'm paranoid wait you haven't i have
alopecia i think do you really no you
have the jada pig i have male pattern
baldness i don't think it's the same i
was like yeah i was like actually you
don't have to validate whatever that is
too thick two things i wanted to get
into because everybody has to cover is
the will smith thing but i also want to
hear about your first show yeah oh
[ __ ] crazy yeah it was crazy
it did look a little wild yeah i'm glad
you didn't come because i want to punch
you in the face i'm glad i didn't go
either after it looked
clip i understand why you didn't want
ben harper fans there
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
it was like the perfect first show
an escape it's a skate shop slash record
shop called program in fullerton
and like they're they're known for like
holding like
little shows like that for like you know
punk bands and hardcore fans all that
stuff so it's like
you know
people watching in front of you yeah
yeah
people were duped it was
it was pretty dope because like
you know i had a lot of people show up
that were actually like fans of like my
comedy
and also fans of the music that i
listened to so it's kind of cool
to see them like show up
the intersection of that venn diagram is
your people like yeah it was like it was
like oh [ __ ] like it you know and i just
think it's fun like you know
i don't know like i when i think back to
being a kid i've always done anything
and everything i wanted to [ __ ] do
and everything that i want to do i want
to be really good at it i don't do a lot
of things but the things i do
you know i want to be good so i yeah i
went back in like was like watching my
tape you know singing is [ __ ] hard
live and like the lung could be
performing too though you're moving
performing and moving around and [ __ ]
like that so it's it's [ __ ] tough you
know what i mean so like the thing i
need to work on is like
you know strengthening the lung capacity
is that the way to say that
strengthening a little bit yeah or just
improving increasing your lung capacity
yeah
i messed up i had it lined up for t5k i
have to bring it up on thursday oh it's
really yeah yeah oh good and then and
then that could be like a nice segue out
on t5k where you talk about this show
possibly that we do oh yeah by the way
that's a great idea that's a great point
chappelle you have to or cat yeah my
memories it helps the network even if we
said it to brendan i'm sure he'd be yeah
yeah we should no it was it was dope a
lot of people showed up had a lot of
love i i just loved that i was able to
perform songs that i wrote
and in front of people that's so dope
that you write your songs too yeah yeah
yeah i uh all the songs that we
performed
uh the the out of all the originals all
of them yes
can we find that music anywhere if we
aren't at a show no we don't have a we
don't have anything recorded yet got it
so our next thing is studio and that's
why i kind of like
i just wanted to do a show and just kind
of like throw this throw it out there
just to see that's before and then now
we're going to like put out music
because people were like yeah your
band's feeling really good yeah so it
was it was actually kind of cool to hear
it was really good it was really tight
you guys must have rehearsed you went no
no i
yeah
the rehearsal we had before the show we
did a three-hour rehearsal where we just
like they're drilling really good our
songs and you know and i was really
happy because my voice wasn't shot the
next day oh nice i've been doing vocal
warm-ups
you don't know about that i was going to
say with the breath you should look into
wim hof not not even oh yeah that um
ice man yeah yeah
you know uh you know that's what uh
travis barker
did to help him uh get back into flying
again oh really i'll do relaxing right
calms anxiety yeah yeah because i didn't
know and i didn't know that's what that
breathing technique
uh it's got a lot of benefits oh yeah
tons a lot of fighters do it right
mm-hmm
there's just a lot of stuff you like if
you're combining the breath work with
like
cold therapy and then yeah going i don't
know all about it i'm saying you should
look into it i should look into it yeah
everybody yeah yeah but uh i feel like i
when i'm like working out it this isn't
it but there's a lot of like breaths out
so you're expelling carbon dioxide from
what i understand and if you do that
when you're feeling really tired during
a workout i feel like that helps just as
much as taking like a deep breath in
nick you are smarter than a fifth grader
oh we got one guy um he just emailed
before the show but he said he's got a
12 year old that's ready to roll really
yeah yeah
that is technically sixth grade so i
don't know
well i feel like that then is a bit of
the
level playing field the sixth grader
versus like any one of us because we're
not smarter than fifth graders with the
exception of nick so it might just kind
of even out a sixth grader versus one
also we're so far removed from fifth
grade yeah that it's like some of that
[ __ ] like obviously when
you know the things i didn't know when
you said the answers it's like of course
yes we learned that so long ago and yeah
it's just not something i would think
about like oh in fifth grade like i
don't know just we need a refresher we
need a refresher so actually it's fair
that the 12 year old is gonna take the
[ __ ] take up the challenge that's
crazy so do you have more shows uh uh no
not lined up i wanna i wanna get
something recorded yeah cause like
music's like different than comedy like
music you gotta give something people
something for them to take home you know
what i mean in like you know they can
take home songs and stuff like that so
it's like i gotta give them something
and i can't just like do shows as like
if i'm a comedian and then all of a
sudden just drop a
you know an album like that but like we
we have some possible gigs lined up
later in june in orange county san diego
and sf it's so interesting because you
have such like a
i don't know like a framework built
already like you could go like as fast
as you want with this i feel like i can
start like perform performing all that
you know and i'm not saying i'm of his
caliber but my idol
i really love donald glover oh yeah i
love dr glover because
he does
the things he wants to [ __ ] do and he
does some really [ __ ] good yeah like
when he did stand up he was really good
at it um a writer you know being a
writer on shows acting
uh
his music yeah you know
like
i appreciate that and i love
what you know
i love people like that you know i'm not
saying i'm donald glover when he first
started rapping people talked like mad
[ __ ] and just making fun of them and
stuff yeah which people are probably
going to [ __ ] make fun of me for this
[ __ ] but it's like this ain't got
nothing to do with you [ __ ] i
think it's surprising i think it
surprised people when donald glover did
like
rapid stuff whereas this has always been
part of your
interest
personality yeah yeah so no one it
doesn't seem inauthentic yeah because
and also like
like i know a lot like a lot of people
like this is like
you know this is like the only thing
they do you know
and so like i want to respect those
people
and you know be good at it like i don't
want to just be like
coming up coming in here and like you
know i don't know because i i respect
this so much and it's like if i respect
it so much then it's like you got to
actually be [ __ ] good at it like you
can't just like come in here and just
[ __ ] you know oh i'm a mega band and
it's just kind of like do it just to do
it no i'm i actually want to be good at
it you know what i mean like i'm
actually [ __ ] looking up like vocal
you know classes and stuff just to kind
of
help a little bit because yeah like i've
never sang before and
you know you never sing before
not like that oh wow you're singing all
the time but not on stage and no fun
but you've done it at some of your
friends shows yeah
yeah my favorite video was uh
there's a video clip it's it's on my
band uh
there's a dope part where everybody's
where i jump in them like mosh yeah pit
with everybody
actually go to youtube
meatball
sandwich
sub at subway pepperoni
type in mad peaceful band you not smell
peaceful
i'm not casey
drew
scroll
scroll
where the hell is it
do you have like a channel you can look
up
no
so
fast forward
to like towards the end closer towards
the end right here go go back a little
bit
let's go back a little bit
go back
all right hit play maybe
oh yeah this part
i'm so exhausted this is the last song
we did but my favorite part
is i show you how exhausted i am
[Music]
[Music]
i'm amazed that this is your first time
like singing as a performance i throw
the bike down
i'm so exhausted you saying though
yeah but that's for my friends and i
just do like a 30-second part
what are you saying yeah i think you
were you sung at some shows before yeah
yeah
why was that funny i don't know
look at watch look how exactly i am all
right
[Music]
[Laughter]
but i made it seem like i was embracing
everything and i was like
i'm just tired
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's perfect
[Music]
it was [ __ ] fun though i had a blast
and you know hell yeah yeah it was good
i love the name
oh cause yeah i feel like that's just me
yeah yeah it's like it's totally my vibe
right just like that's who i am as a
person
right i want to be your best manager
where's the merch let's get let's do
some shows dude one of my buddies have
him shout out to my buddy tim milhouse
he uh he works for a much emergency
company uh dirt bike or whatever uh did
i do twitch
uh motocross dude
and um
he surprised me at the first show or at
our show
with uh
shirts for my band and i was like what
the [ __ ] it was
yeah it was so sweet so we i do have
shirts i don't have a lot left because i
i just gave everybody for free and i was
like just rock the rock the merch and
just [ __ ]
you know support our
you know can we see that merch anywhere
do you have a photo of it
or did you just give out all the shirts
no i don't have a photo of it what i'm
sorry dude it's okay it just says mad
peaceful
but cool the fact that he actually made
them yeah yeah
it'd be cool to see him i don't know
dude i was i was [ __ ] pretty happy
with myself you should be happy you know
i was actually pretty happy with myself
it was a great job and uh
i don't know just having the fact that i
was just like man i [ __ ] did
something i wanted to do and i was like
i actually took the time to like want to
be good because i listen i've thrown
away so many [ __ ] songs because i'm
like nope not good enough nope not good
enough
and like it's taking me like a long time
to like really narrow it down
to like how i want to sound and what i
want to do you ever heard of the war of
art
yeah i love that [ __ ] book steven
pressfield yeah you just gotta
let stuff out and doing the concert is
like i feel like now you're doing it and
yeah it's that like you threw away all
those songs but you finally just did it
and now you're doing it dude that book
specifically i don't know if you guys
have read it but that was the book i'm
gonna be honest i don't read
i don't you know i used to read a lot of
mythology but like no not anymore but
she has a degree
i don't have a degree so i got to read i
barely got that degree oh no it's also
in theater i don't think
but that book is the book that like set
the tone for me in l.a when i moved to
l.a because i had it for i had that book
a long time
war of art stoicism
it's crazy i'm telling you it's [ __ ]
crazy because
my friend gave gave me that book and i
had it for a really [ __ ] long time
and then i i didn't read it until the uh
the day after i moved to l.a and i read
that book and i was just like oh [ __ ]
and it just set it off yeah
do you feel like that book kind of set
the tone for your like your life here in
l.a yep and kind of like gave you that
foundation of how you're going to
[ __ ] time
big [ __ ] time
and as a man thinketh you never heard
that moment
i think the last time i tried to read
something something along those lines
was
at the very beginning of the pandemic
like 2020 just
2019 just ended i was getting out of a
relationship and everyone at that time
was posting this book and i saw it
everywhere on my feet it was uh
the art of not giving a [ __ ] oh yeah
like everyone
and i remember buying it because i
wanted to see what the fuss was all
about and i was reading it and not that
it's a bad book it's a good book it's
just all things i felt like i didn't
need someone to tell me this that's a
lot oh really yeah because it was a lot
of like
uh yeah excuse me i've had people
recommend it to me but i'm like
a lot of the concepts in that book
i feel like you already have a handle on
it's a lot of
like
you focus on you and what you want to do
everything else is just noise kind of
like trying to be stoicism yeah oh god
but in a different form
yeah i think the
the hook of like the subtle art of not
giving a [ __ ] kind of reels people in
and if you don't have a reference for
any uh
like stoicism then you kind of that
that's a good entry way to get it yeah
it's but if you already kind of have it
like i was raised buddhist so i kind of
already knew some of these things no
yeah i just be thinking about [ __ ] not
just be like
like for instance i remember there was
this one time
someone said uh
a fan had wrote to me i mean i don't
know how true of a fan they were but
they're like i lost all respect for you
for something i don't know something you
remember the reason podcast and the
reasons are always so hard i don't
remember because it was like something
so stupid yeah but like this person said
they lost all respect for me but it's
like
i didn't know you existed i like what
you said you know what i mean like i
don't think they were a true fan like if
so you say one thing and someone jumps
off ship like yeah like you weren't
really on the ship yeah
i'm like first of all i didn't know you
existed i don't know who you are so it's
like i mean some people like that would
hit yeah they'd be like oh my god that
[ __ ] person lost me i'm like and i'm
pretty sure other people too but i'm
like
what do you want me to do with this
information i don't even know who you
are you lost respect for me
what are you my mom like if you're my
mom you said that it'd be a different
story but like you're a person i
literally did not know existed
yeah and it's not necessarily in a bad
way trying to demean them no it's just
it's just like
like it's a it's a what do i do with
this info yeah so yeah what do you want
to do with this information that's what
i how i feel about it like did you want
an apology yeah did you want i don't
yeah i don't know what i mean and a lot
of times and listen to keep my [ __ ]
sanity i do block a lot of people i do
[ __ ] delete people's dumb [ __ ]
comments but that's mainly
so i don't go crazy yeah it's it's the
way to do it i like you know like
there's i've i seriously
you have to just look at the percentage
of people are like listening to shows
and then like the amount of comments you
have you can get rid of like like if you
go to the live chat of like a premiere
of king and the sting people will flood
the chat and they'll troll it and like
there's old there's old trolling things
that people will do like joe rogan rip
joe rogan so people will say that's a
thing they'll just say that over and
over and over and then you remove that
person and you remove like six people
and all of a sudden the chat's normal
but
those six people could make it
unreadable they could just yeah yeah
they could do just spam spam so it seems
like it's coming more but if you do
block those people
all of a sudden it gets like way calmer
and like yeah
because honestly it's first of all it's
the i created my own [ __ ] instagram
so it's like why i can't control it like
i can't [ __ ] block someone that i
don't want to [ __ ] yeah or delete
some dumb [ __ ] comment that someone
said hey i mean i'll give a [ __ ]
a second chance
you know what i mean but after that you
do another dumb comment i'm like hey
[ __ ] welcome to my blog i can't even
remember them though if it's the same oh
unless they're like just such a dude
like a lot of people are like uh we i
remember fans there's times i'll go back
to cities and i'll go i remember you
chapelle has great memories that's
awesome that's a really good memory
there's people that came to the show i
said i met you guys in brea right what
yeah and they fan for life then they
were like holy [ __ ] yeah yeah i have a
good memory that's amazing my memory is
[ __ ]
you know because you don't drink anymore
which is great yeah because i don't
drink no more
and the magic mine helps me out yeah
focus but not wired yeah focus would not
work probably i can remember things and
drink
all right nick wanted to talk about it
let's [ __ ] talk about it speaking of
that spam situation of like removing
people from the chat because i can make
it unreadable
something that i found so interesting
about like korean uh pop star culture is
that so many fans of these k-pop groups
will do that but with support so
i remember seeing an article about one
of the members of bts receiving a lot of
backlash for something he had said and
it wasn't anything crazy but it's
something that got blown up because they
have such a large platform and their
fans
on twitter said let's leave a purple
heart under his account and all of his
latest posts to flood out
and so they'll go and they'll
like post a bunch of purple hearts to
show their support to him and then the
hate is unreadable so it's like the
reverse got you
which is insane that's why to me bts
fans are some of the scariest people
they're a group of 16 year olds
internationally who will hack your [ __ ]
and [ __ ] your life up for yourself
because i have a strong fan base that is
[ __ ] unreal like obviously this you
got this swiss swifties that was the top
of my head the beehive the beehive the
barbs
i thought it was the knife oh yes uh
that's fair though yeah
i thought it was a beehive yeah but yeah
those uh wwe fans wwe fans are crazy
yeah
huge um yeah there's like you could
tweet something not tag anybody not
hashtag anything about any one of these
people or wwe and you'll get people that
have are searching that name out just to
like attack billy eilish fans european
fans
die like some die hard like die hard
dare talk [ __ ] about my [ __ ] euphoria
yeah like they're like that mm-hmm like
uh do you know who tom has got any fans
like that what do you mean that ride or
dive for you nick
uh i mean it's yeah it's a it's a
different set that they're usually also
below deck or bachelor fans
but he's got him i got we guys got that
yeah
um
i'll have to think about it right you we
need we need like a beehive swifty thing
for you yeah can we say
but you say it please
and i and i see
k-e-r-s okay e-r-s knickers yeah but
like just like the new york knicks
that and like underwear sounds like
something theo would come up with yeah
because he knew the answer oh right
because i've seen him perform
like at least a thousand times rhode
island kids uh no chin you got you and
cat can say me and nick just can't say
it really say what
i'm like
what he just spelled out i mean if you
can enunciate i don't know i can't i'm
not necessarily
who are you i can't enough say [ __ ] so
i'm not even taking the risk you rhode
island kids
he's also part of a
blm so shout out to all my knickers
it is thin ice
my heart drops
you got to hit the consonants
yeah i heard it in the headphones i was
like wait we'll try some something
without yeah
i mean we have names for uh kind of a
triumvirate me dylan and pat who have
another podcast network the bachelor
fans are the baby birds the below deck
fans are the baby barnacles i i don't
like to like shine a spotlight on
someone they tried to help me out with
one for uh chappelle's world what did
they they said cheer squad i was like
i'm not calling you [ __ ] the
sheer squad you're so polite and just
emoji friendly on instagram you i was
like i love the cheer squad you're like
yeah but you're like [ __ ] the cheers
because this is like these do you not
want it cheer related
uh i like keeping things separate yeah
i don't want to dis i'm a cheerleader
alumni and i don't want to disrespect
the map
yeah you can't disrespect the match no
do not disrespect the man i was a badass
cheerleader bro you were better than
anything you've ever done in your life i
wouldn't go that far
yeah you were working every day i'm a
world champ [ __ ]
that's what's always funny whenever
people when it's very rare
very very very [ __ ] rare that
anyone's ever tried to make fun of me
about cheer mm-hmm i go oh what have you
want at the highest level and you're in
your thing
that shuts them up a lot of real players
these [ __ ] haven't done
anything
they just played in junior high
world champions
got a world champion of the [ __ ]
football team
suddenly chapel is no longer stoic
sorry oh sorry sorry
i love everybody
i'm just a fan of the world
uh bad segway this is something i wanted
to bring up last week though uh a couple
weeks ago we who was it that same it was
a doji cat that had the uh they're
talking about the taco bell yeah
uh what are you doing
my contacts messed up oh why use this
hand though no i don't know it happens i
want to cover them what a way to do it
you can't cover up the moneymaker
i was stretching it was over there
that's like some lady gaga [ __ ]
dramatic cute super
poker face or uh or did you see um julia
fox's outfit this weekend which one it
was like the hand on her throat oh yeah
when like fashion has a chokehold on you
yeah is that i didn't i didn't know what
it was from i just thought clips of it
she's [ __ ]
she is
i think she's doing this very
deliberately having these like
outrageous kind of like weirdly ill
fitted
outfits that don't look great yes
ill-conceived there we go i think this
is all very purposeful yeah because she
no longer has the relationship with
kanye to kind of
boost her star power so now it's like
let's do fashion but like
bad so people have something to say it's
almost kind of like the kardashian thing
where it's like as no publicity is bad
publicity i think that's what she's
doing
is that black swan it seems to be
working i don't think so that might be
satan inspired her eyes are right i
think that's [ __ ] kanye inspired it
reminds me of black swan that's what i'm
saying
did i say it right black swan
i think you said uh wait that's a white
swan
i think you said i think he said black
black yeah i think it's a blessing then
yes and cat is completely disregarded
yeah you're right
you're like no yeah it reminds me of
black swan
you're right the makeup reminds me of
black swan what was this event cat uh
that was a vanity fair after party
that's usually like the place to be
after the oscars no one really cares
about the oscars anymore it's about the
after party it's about the fashion the
looks uh she was talking to someone and
they were asking about her memoir and
she's like she's like yeah i'm a little
superstitious so i don't really want to
say too much about before it's finished
but
it seems like it's a masterpiece
do you see that did we watch it on here
she's from italy that caller daddy promo
where she's like oh yeah uncut gems
huh
that one or no the collard
where she's talking about like no one
deserves the [ __ ] yeah
caller daddy promo julia fox but the
reason i brought this up there's another
uh hip hop star who did a fast food
jingle did you guys see push it oh push
your teeth
it was like a
rv that was four that was a commercial
uh
yes he got paid for it first i want to
see this this trailer
uh this is oh this is the actual thing
just do callers on their instagram promo
oh that was the first one
six minutes something that's like a
minute
julia fox reveals
uh dominatrix maybe type in instagram i
think if you go to the instagram and
scroll down to
just whatever video julia fox is in
you'll be able to see it because it
didn't happen that long ago
this it yeah yeah
she was a guest don't call her daddy yes
at the [ __ ] they'll never be good
enough for the [ __ ] start over yeah
they need to know that they will never
be worthy to have that like the the
[ __ ] they'll never be good i love her
slight list
it's adorable
isn't it a kanye song i love this
trailer because this is during like the
height of their relationship because my
feet
i could smother them maybe sit on their
face like with my panties but they'll
never ever be good enough for my vagina
i'm into like weirdly like
like partner like swapping and then like
watching or something
or something
[Applause]
you're dating someone new
have you guys put a label on it what was
your first impression of do you think
kanye's boots are sexy how did you guys
leave it before you went to new york why
do you not consider it what do you say
to people who claim this is not a real
relationship have you ever felt in these
moments like a little overwhelmed no
[Laughter]
i love the way they got it
so she was in uncut gym she's the girl
that like plays his mistress
i believe so i didn't finish
i don't know
i fell asleep he stresses me out i
forgot i was in mistress not fall asleep
during that because i was working a lot
there it's a loss yeah i was gonna say
well no cause you like you just said
that stressed me out so much i wasn't
able to sleep like i was like yeah i
wasn't able to finish that this is
stressing me out
wait so you did you finish it yeah
did you finish it nick what okay
no i haven't seen it but it's like i i i
want to see it oh
i saw it oh
yeah she's known as like the hot girl
in
uncut jumps is it she's like the yeah i
believe
i'm not sure if it was a mistress or not
it was this chick
but i i thought it was like his side it
might have been that's what i don't
remember right now
i don't know
but what about that but that's her
culture what do you mean her culture i
mean that that's how she gets down um i
don't say culture i don't mean like oh
this is for white no yeah and you like
everybody everybody has their own
individual culture
that's what i mean by that because she
talked about how she used to be a
dominatrix that was part of the promo
cut
oh god so i think she's talking about
like what she used to do as a dominant
dominatrix is her culture her culture
yes and that's fine
that's fine bdsm that's
those are people what's that rihanna
song
yeah s m yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so i was like i know nickel knowing
so many [ __ ] songs
she's like my no i mean i just have i
don't see her as much anymore but uh
she's like my number one celebrity
anytime people be like oh rank your
you know your celebrity crushes or
whatever she's number one i remember
josh wolfe saying that he was at an
event that she was at and that she was
the most beautiful woman he's ever seen
strictly based off of her confidence
alone he's like when she walks in she
knows she's the baddest [ __ ] and it's
so attractive yes bad girl
you know who else i think is one of the
most naturally beautiful women on the
planet i'm just saying this story to
humblebrag
cassie
oh like the
yeah okay i loved her when i was in high
school
and then she came on the joe coy show
and i was like behind the glass
and i felt like i was very funny and
made a bunch of jokes
she followed me she was only following
600 people i i was like just one day
i'll i'll use this dm i never did and
then one day like a year and a half
later she was following zero people
or like one brand or something it must
have been like a deal but yeah [ __ ] it
she she like six million followers filed
six hundred that was one of them bro i
wonder if it wasn't right she was still
following no
uh alex fine is his name that's her uh i
believe they're married now no he was uh
diddy's former personal trainer he used
to train her too that's how they met oh
okay
whoa beautiful man we could have got our
own cats after darkness yeah
i know hey cass you remember me i made
those funny jokes made you laugh mm-hmm
got you to follow me
and then you unfollowed me maybe i'm
about to touch his head open on some
ditty [ __ ] yeah
life of pablo i can't remember the song
but maybe we should get we uh maybe we
can get pusha t on if we show the arby's
ad
the video good good
smart let's let's see it this is so
forced george is coming and we're gonna
talk to george what up george hey so
pusha t did this because he created the
mcdonald's in the whole world
i remember seeing that you should be
disgusting
a half slice of cheese mickey d's on a
budget army's crispy fish is simply it
with lines around the corner we might
need a guest list exit stage left the
sandwiches taste fresh a little cuba
fish from a clown is basic
this argument is baseless drowned and
soldered that fellaio fish is tasteless
he came after drake and now he's coming
after mcdonald
jesus
nobody is safe from pusha t i could sell
water to a whale how could you ever
think i fell
yeah
the crispy fish sandwich plays in trails
the mother clown's just too frail
yeah
dude someone's gonna get shot over fast
food chicken sandwiches
fish fish sandwiches
people got shot over the
chicken sandwiches from papaya
right
and honestly after having one don't
blame the guy for doing it they're worth
it it was really good yeah it was good
i'd stab someone for one good sandwich i
really pigeon hold that in there but you
thought the pusha t
the whole thing listen that is [ __ ]
so he came up with i'm loving it i guess
do you know the exact backstory or did
he make a song too i'm loving it i
believe he came up with the jingle and
he was like
yeah and then like years later uh justin
timberlake came up with like a rendition
of that after the jingle was already
made mm-hmm oh that's my knowledge
yeah it was actually originally the song
originally written as
a jingle for american fast food chains
was produced by the neptunes which is
credited as being written by pharrell
williams
but the connection to neptune's pharrell
he worked with pushing
yeah i loved clips back in the day
eclipse grind i know that
oh whoa dude grinding
hello whoa dude
it came out of nowhere
i love that out virginia yeah i'm from
virginia where ain't [ __ ] to do but cook
pack it up sell it something i don't
know it's super hot he knows it all he
really does who's the other guy in clips
was that his brother am i tripping i
don't know let's find out
christian got google
that was that was
group the other part i don't think they
spelled it there clips with the e the
other part of that grinding
[Applause]
uh we got george in here hey jonathan
george introduce yourself george where
were that new on this oh sorry what's up
george as close as you can to the mic
and feel free to pull it towards you i
would even i would actually move up so
christian's not blocking george
can you do this no
i'm not good at that yeah i can't even
like i literally haven't done that since
junior high it sounds good in the
headphones
that sounds good he was doing it can you
do it i did it before
oh wow wait what i've got bigger cheeks
than anyone here though you do have you
do have big shoulders cheeks george how
old are you 25 25 yeah that's right yeah
let's learn about you george you're 25
where are you from born and raised
glendale california so pretty good
croatian but
i get that a lot because it's glendale
so
if you drive the white beamer then
you grew up in glendale you said it like
you were on the tv show next yeah i grew
up in glendale california
right here you know
that show was amazing right i love the
fun facts that they would give after
their age and where they're from it's
like thought guacamole came from guacs
yes i love [ __ ] like that what's your
random fact
random fact um
my grandparents came from croatia and
decided to live in bakersfield
california
shout out to corn yeah grapes no the
band oh cool
wow how dare you just corn with a k what
are they from bakersfield or something i
don't know i don't know any like band
names around all right i'll give you
okay okay you're gonna have a new guy
he's trying to explain himself this is
about him i know this is what this is
what we're learning so he doesn't know
anything about music
um
what did you do before this
um i actually was living in croatia for
like 10 months and i came back
probably a couple days before christmas
oh really yeah we're going to
just hang out with you they have like a
birthright kind of program thing there
and what does it like rump springer
whatever that is yes
it's just a funny word i know what she
meant what is it
is a break from being amish yeah three
months to [ __ ] people yeah uh it's not
like that uh it's basically just like um
they want to get uh croatians like
outside of croatia to come back to the
country and learn about the culture
learn the language so they paid for me
and my friend to like live there
basically so i was working in finance
actually and i was like i'm over this
it's quarantine everything sucks i'm
just going to go to croatia oh supposed
to be like three months but i stayed for
almost a year i think the middle east
office as well in israel
yeah a jewish one
somewhere no they yes
yeah i think i think ari manas did it
yeah oh yeah yeah i think arnold managed
i had a friend that i don't think
they're very strict or like look at her
like jewish identity very much because i
had a friend that pretended to be jewish
and he did it he did it got it all for
free so i wonder if africa does this
[ __ ] that two friends did that actually
yeah how would they know that sounds
awesome but also like risky business
like with i don't know would there be
consequences
yeah i know yeah that seems kind of like
israel doesn't i love that though yeah i
think they just like call you up and
like are you jewish and they're like
yeah and then it's like okay
because i mean what more what more
questions could you [ __ ] ask because
you could always convert after the trip
if you weren't jewish to begin with
true or convert before the trip yeah
true well for this croatia thing i had
to like give my grandparents birth
certificates oh it was actually oh god
they were like they were yeah so they
thought they were gonna roll up yeah
they're like what are your thoughts on
harry potter
if you marry a creation though you can
do it i can roll up yeah they they allow
that spouses oh
so like croatian by association yeah so
there's a relationship st anthony's
downtown i can take you we can uh oh
foreign
he said meet some girls
you are on next
this [ __ ] guy
i like you george
so what do you end up doing for 10
months out there
a lot of down time yeah a lot of down
time um we had class for like just two
hours a day like croatian language class
and that was pretty much it like
yeah obviously um
you can finish your thought i'm just
pointing at you because i i want to know
something oh i thought you were asking
i want to hear you say something
hey
that's me saying i speak croatian but
very poorly
oh wow
hey that was me yeah sounds like a
little like russian almost they're like
slavic
i'm like the ukrainians yeah what's the
point for you all right you ready let's
do it
famous
croatian bass player
bass player
um christo
um
what's his last name
is he on um
on the nirvana right or not nirvana am i
close or you're there yeah what's his
last name uh
don't look it up meatball oh sorry i
forget his last name but i know nobody
that's i don't know i'm not saying it
i'm saying obviously the [ __ ] yeah
american american way yeah there's a
christmas yeah there's an interview
somewhere um on youtube of him like
speaking relationship yeah
yeah
you do know music [ __ ] you're a
liar
no there's no there's not a lot of us so
when someone does something cool you're
like ah yeah yeah is
now i'm kidding
is yugoslavia still a place no it's not
it used to be croatia was a part of
yugoslavia okay yeah was tony from
croatia he's croatian
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah and hating chirokulu
he's not he was not but he was
yugoslavia yeah
what about hayden panetta no i think
she's american oh okay the question is
she's married to a youtube american
she's in the news too right now oh that
guy and her husband yeah
yeah i think
uh her ex-husband yeah vladimir the
father of her
yeah there's those pictures of him and
her and she's just yeah she's tiny he's
gigantic because i think she's mine
and then meatball
to the left
to the left
i didn't know this i thought you were
saying that chappelle because of the how
similar the name sounded i was like i
was funny i was just being a well that
has a next level too that was really
funny
i love it what's up george do you know
who you know the famous
fighters she's dating vladimir putin
pro cop yes you do know awesome wait
hey meatball hit back
how do you say stipe's name yeah stipe
miochi yeah she is [ __ ] yeah
that's what i've been saying
but it's been meatballs
in his first fight they pronounced it
yeah or something like that which is
wrong yeah
is he the pride and joy oh you wanted
him in it too oh yeah yeah
who else is a prime joy like if it's
steeping and then who else would be
notable in the country
probably can croatian
yeah but they're like some basketball
players like the clippers have evie
zubats um there's dario saric
um who else is there
bogdanovic on the jazz a lot of he's
funny
yeah
and then the croatian like the whole
national soccer team yeah amazing how
did you guys get so tall
i don't know but like i'm like fairly
tall but when i go over there i'm like
looking up at people really yeah they're
tall
i actually appreciate the fact that
you're like you're able to do that like
go back you know to the motherland and
uh yeah it's cool you know learn about
like
you know pretty much where you come from
that's dope well my grandparent because
i'm correlation on both sides so my
grandparents did a good job of like
instilling in us like this is where you
guys come from and that's dope we had
cousins from over there come here went
over there a few times before i did this
long sabbatical um so it's yeah it's
definitely a cool thing i think if
everybody understood that they wouldn't
be such [ __ ] do you think they have
a correlation where they come from yeah
they just understood where they come
from less ignorance overall i think
would help that that's what i'm looking
for ignorance yeah uh
when i said you how did you get so tall
i meant you as a people not you
specifically yeah yeah i know
i got it i just worked my ass off you
know
i i felt like i i just decided i wanted
to be 16. you decided yeah and i just
just
and i got it it hasn't worked for me in
my head i think i'm as tall as chappelle
but i know physically i'm not well
because you thought you were that tall
so you gave up we almost cause like i
kept trying because something i do is i
think i'm tall but i know i'm not taller
than stevie physically mentally i think
i am so when we argue i like to pretend
like i'm walking up the stairs and i'll
stay on the second step and argue from
like to him looking down at him so he
knows what height i think i am
he doesn't like that meatball look up
google if tumbling stunts your growth i
wonder why it does i wonder if i'm still
that was a big uh like wise tale it does
no i remember i'm reading about it
because yeah weightlifting all that
tumbling i was doing i wonder if that
stopped me from being [ __ ] six foot
because you're five eleven
five
yeah there's something about
muscle using your muscles when you're
young to not yeah cause i started doing
flips when i was like five
um
but yeah when you're tumbling you're
actually like putting pressure on to
those like i remember reading about it
like it does it's not your growth for
some people yeah there's like
all
i don't think it's a coincidence that
like professional gymnasts are short i
don't think you have to be sure to be a
gymnast i think you know from a young
age
then you're then you're short yeah
because everyone in my family is taller
than me
damn is your sister taller than you too
no because i know your brother was no no
my brother was she's not george what do
you do here and how do you feel about
pretty soon you might have to be george
number two yeah i know we've talked
about nicknames and stuff um
george number two because george harris
uh are
oh yes our boy who's lost uh
nearly 300 pounds yeah uh he's going to
be uh entering into a boy over the
summer oh hell yeah and ev yeah he's
he's sorry mike started calling me g
which is behind people called me that
before oh really um
they were saying maybe we'll call you
georgie i'm like chill with that yeah
i'm trying to push uh i'm the third so
i'm trying to push gd3 because you know
if you're the third you gotta have like
some sick initials like cp3 yeah exactly
like chris paul rg3 or e.t i see what
you did there hey i respect that yeah
cd3 or what is it
sorry gd3 that's you
what's your way what's your last name uh
dolcich dosage it's sich yeah this is
why isn't it
that's what that is that's the like
correct croatian way to announce but i
guess like kind of got americanized
there were already people with my last
name who came from croatia like to
america before my grandparents did so i
think they kind of just fell in tow
with like the way they made them change
their name at lsu island and they added
an h at the end um because it's in
croatian it's d u l c i c but like the
cs have the accent marks on the top so
like the h at the end makes the ch but
and you'd kind of have to add another h
in the middle of
the last name and that would look kind
of weird so i figured they'd just say uh
dulce so it's like h is oh yeah
i get you yeah i see you [ __ ] i
like it
uh
but i'm going to be doing a thick boy
social over here
and i'm kind of on a trial period right
now so
how do you think you're doing he's
killing it so far we uh we're like i
guess i got the account like a week ago
today and we're up over 2 000 followers
hell yeah
put in the application or the request
for verification and it's just much
easier to grow it when it's your only
responsibility yeah no one should feel
bad yeah they're not doing it anymore
no i don't i feel so much better because
it's just i think that was also to me i
feel like this is definitely the best oh
no i was getting jokes oh okay it seemed
like a more direct awkward thing
happening right there i see how much
like you have to do so yeah it helps so
much
he's got headphones
is the same zoom meeting up on that that
thing because jack said his invite's not
working
well i don't know your password to your
laptop oh it turned off
no it's on live
although i hope you know we're not i
only know that song because it was on
one of the shrek movies oh really yeah
oh
i know because it was an escape video
that's the only reason
well glad to have you here george yeah
i'm excited to be here be honest how do
you like working at thick boys so so far
if anything is bad we'll cut it out it's
fine be honest
that's been really cool so far i mean
i've only been here a week and kind of
see a lot of cool people rolling in the
fight companion was cool so
i guess as far as jobs go like this is
pretty good yeah yeah what made you want
to
like get a job here
um well i've always been like super in
the comedy and all that kind of world
and i've actually like me and my friends
made this like stupid sketch comedy um
channel that we were posting stuff on
like tik tok and insta so that was kind
of like a creative outlet i do a little
stand up too so it was always like i'd
like to make this like an actual like
job and i was working in finance and
kind of doing that stuff on the side so
when i came back i was like all right
like i'm gonna like i'm not doing any of
that stuff i don't enjoy anymore i'm
gonna try and get into the world that i
want to be in so i came back i was like
i don't care like i'm just going to get
a job
on some like podcasts or like funny
media company and i don't care how it
happens but i'm going to do it and tell
you a friend sent me kyle story saying
that they were looking for people to add
to the social media team so i hit him up
and it's like oh i'm in la i have a car
um there you go
yeah yeah i threw that in there because
i was like okay like it's calabasas yeah
who knows are you still living in
glendale yeah oh okay yeah nice i i
spent like all my money when i was in
curly shift for a year i wasn't working
so i was like i need to save some money
living at home yeah oh you live with
your folks right yeah there ain't
nothing wrong with that reasonable
reasonable
100 i'll live with my folks in a
heartbeat at 35
was yeah with them last year the white
folks who adopted you or
i just wanted to see them i know maybe
something changed
my mom was in the same neighborhood i
grew up you're like new i ain't going
back no i'm just kidding
wouldn't i say nick you
i lost it i lost it i was excited about
it i was excited about oh what's your
favorite thing that you have on the
internet that we could watch short
jack shores favorite thing well we
actually it's not very short but we have
a like we went around zagreb which is
the capital of croatia right before the
sepe fight
with the francis and like interviewed
people i think that was like seven
thousand views on youtube and got like
13 000 on instagram um
what what's it called um
wait the first fight or second part the
second fight so we woke up at like 4 a.m
to watch it and then he got knocked out
it kind of sucked um and then kind of
killed the video too because it's like
no one's going to be watching this after
he gets knocked out hey that first fight
sleeping that stressed me out that's
like one of my favorite fights dog house
stressed me out so much every time he
got hit
i love i love stipe so much he seems
like such a nice
wholesome man
i want nothing more than for him to like
have a healthy life
yeah he
uh works as a firefighter when he's not
fighting well i think he did it at the
same time while tv i think he's he's
part-time right now but he does it as
he's yeah fighting and he does twitch
now i believe i think yeah i think he
plays video games online too
way more than any of us do
i feel like i'm i take note of a lot of
people who
do gaming stuff just because like i used
to watch a bunch of gaming videos yeah
let's watch this i love the matching
fits you lost bro you lost weight yeah
you lost what yeah i was like croatian
was feeding you know right i was like uh
before i left i don't know why i was
just like
i'm gonna do a big bulk and like but
like super dirty and i was like i'm
gonna get up to like 2 30. for no reason
like i have no reason to be that heavy i
was just like i'm gonna do it
so i was like 220 right there i'm like
190 right now damn damn as soon as i got
over there and i wasn't eating like
home-cooked meals like every day is like
i lost it pretty fast yeah wait is what
you call it from uh
the guitar player the original guitar
player for
chili pepper chili pepper chad smith
i know you're talking about the guy that
was on drugs for a long time yeah he
didn't oh no no not john not john not
him no even before that his name is
hillel it's not a croatian oh no wait
uh
i don't even i don't i can't every
camera
no not drummer guitar what do you i
didn't type it
this guy
goes to the right
to the right
no
oh his last name is what slovak yes he's
something over there i don't think
croatian maybe you know maybe slovakian
because his last name is slovak
let's see
israel he was born in
oh interesting oh okay
well because
is it your buddy's last name slovak
zovak
oh i read that wrong i'm sorry but
that's yeah like that that's also oh
that's so bad
my bad
all right let's give this a little watch
to our good friend crow warrior we're
here in the heart of zagreb interviewing
people about the upcoming stupid people
made
come check it out hey don't ever get fat
again you know we're here with let's get
that if you want to get fat
all right we're here with
who am i here talking to
what
some language barrier stuff
what's your name
hi my name is daniel
miroslav
uh i think he's a great uh fighter
great performance so like um he's very
good at uh stand up get my kid off of it
so we spelled out hell shut up
oh he is a really nice fighter possible
the gold
around in the old ufc i think that he
had a rough rough match against dc so i
don't know how much he's left in him so
okay so we got a skeptic
i'm rooting for him but i like sleepy
steep it's a great fighter
ultimate guy's a legend he gave us shots
after that's his bar oh nice sports guy
or something is it pretty much cold
there all the time
in the winter in zagreb but the capital
is kind of in the middle it's freezing
it got really cold yeah but on the coast
it's really warm and nice and kind of
like on the coast over here
no that's dope man george i mean this
respectfully but next time they go
so how much money do you think he would
have gotten if he was on the next 16 you
wanted to take the 16
or you know
yeah it's like the 16 run or go on
another date oh yeah but i said next
yeah
no idea what show you guys are talking
about i've just been going along with it
yeah like that
okay so i mean if you pull it up maybe
i'll know um you are younger than that
i used to watch it
well i'm a little older yeah you want me
to hop out switch the computer you can
you could say if you want yeah and then
bring up bring in jack short
[Music]
oh but really quickly next was a dating
show on mtv where it was like a bus full
of guys or girls coming out one at a
time to try to date the main person and
they could say next if
we're just figuring out the tactical and
we'll be back
oh all right we're good i'm going to hop
out i have some stuff to do with mike so
where's guys hey george i appreciate it
chappelle we'll get that video soon for
social media yes it's the wheel on yeah
yeah yeah i got you
is it working hold on jack
you good say something
yo hear me yeah yeah yeah yeah now you
gotta switch there he is
how's it going
yeah come on good how are you hey come
on man you know i'm great we're talking
we're talking to the future bantamweight
champ in the ufc undefeated 16-0 jack
shorts yeah joe
hell yeah
that's crazy
let's hope so anyway future bantamweight
champ that's the plan yeah of course
i think you get that i knew it years ago
right the first time i saw him fight oh
you did it yeah before i knew he was a
cats fan too i was like just huge jack
shore fan i bet on you every fight
uh and i don't know if you remember this
nick but he does come out to oasis oh
yeah he walks out to asia every time i
know you're super sonic right
yeah supersonic every time yeah the best
way to solve all types
[Laughter]
you know it was sorry i got excited you
know it was super sad was it was it on
the same card that mike yeah obviously
it was in london mike mike grundy
or yeah
wonderful mike grundy no he came out to
uh
something more
american than that and his dad was
singing along with it
it was like here i go again on my own
that's what it came out to someone came
on to something like that it wasn't
wonder wall
but his dad was
yeah he usually does wonderful mike
grundy because he's um
he trains in uh liverpool but i'm pretty
sure he's from manchester united he's
from manchester that's wonderful he may
have changed it because his dad was
there and i know his dad's not well um
oh that was it because
yeah sorry they they whatever song it
was they played recording in progress it
was it was a
nice
huge
huge huge uh now go to gallery view and
then pin
jack shore in the upper right says view
gallery the three dots
pin
nice all right
so that contract it had to be something
with his dad because they he was walking
out super emotional he's singing the
songs they showed his dad his dad
singing every single word and then he
got submitted in the first round yeah uh
by mac one it was it was a bummer why
you bring that up uh because the lockout
the walkout was awesome
yeah sorry you're right you're right but
jack won
jack jack jack
jack won i pulled it back i pulled it
back don't worry
i'll be i'll be in london in june
oh yeah you're coming in you have to see
uh liam gallagher
oh which one you're going through um
yeah yeah
yeah at nebworth
i'm going to i think i'm going to
saturday
i'm waiting on our um i'm waiting to get
a fight confirmed in the summer so i'm
hoping that i can go go up and watch but
obviously i don't want to go up this
over and uh
with all my friends there there's a bit
of a wild bunch to be i'm gonna vote
with silver so yeah i'm hoping that i
get to get the fight before so i can go
and enjoy it a little bit more so i may
see you there hey come on hey hey
i love that it wouldn't be fun if he
wasn't [ __ ] up
i guess
it's a choice
because you want better for yourself
chappelle i want better for myself
hey i always say if i if i grew up out
that way i'd probably be drinking jack i
don't know if you can even talk about
this but were you able to get a fight of
the night bonus behind the scenes at all
no nothing no dude
lames
i know i think any other show in like
the last two years i probably would have
got fights without a fight tonight it's
usually like a one-sided and one time
i'm in a fight that people are saying i
should be fighting tonight they uh
they [ __ ] me off and give them oh man
dude
hopefully something comes later though
yeah
but it's been a little while but
hopefully something comes later i don't
know
do you feel like you're getting a push
from the ufc because like you're
this is this is something i pulled out i
don't know if you know this but the
combined record of your five ufc
opponents is 58 10 and 1.
that's
yeah that's insane teamer valve hadn't
lost in like 20 fights
or 16 fights or something crazy he lost
to tevin jones but then kevin jones
smoked weed it got suspended but
no contest but
nick
but even like that i don't know if you
watched our um that kevin jones fight
like
99 of referees probably would have
stopped that fight in the first round
the other way you know like timur so
like
literally i think this is the first
fight i've been the underdog for for
like five like five or six fights and um
all my all my friends are like rubbing
their hands like we're gonna make we're
gonna we're gonna have a free weekend in
london now we're gonna bet that big and
um like everyone ripped me off before
the fight and it's always the same it's
like they write you off and then and
then when you go out there and put in a
good performance it's like i should have
won that fight anyway you know he's
always gonna win but uh
it is where it is i think um the fact
the fans are back now he's gonna help me
a little bit especially in the uk like
i've got massive falling over here and i
think i was the third fight on the card
and um
there's like videos of my walk out in
the crowds going [ __ ] nuts for uh for
the fir from the third fight then i
maybe if i fought in vegas they'd
probably be known in the arena so uh
yeah hopefully we need some more like uk
shows
what nothing uh
uh technic technical stuff yeah just
technical stuff yeah teaching and
learning you just gotta be on it the
whole time it's like a constant thing
what were you texting i was recording
for thick boy story for the show to
build up the publicity oh there we go so
we got clip yeah i mean
i i that is that is less important than
switching the cameras during a zoom so
if we're just going forward if don't go
yeah
um sorry yeah
i love that jack jack in here watching
we'll cut that part out yeah no we're
leaving it
at the end of this i think i should
probably be able to produce my own
podcast
uh are you're doing a lot of more
immediate stuff i see you're you're
announcing fights uh
are you doing a pod
um not nora porter search i'm trying to
like i'm on i've set like a twitch
channel and my youtube now i've started
doing it properly rather than just you
know filming filming everything on my
phone i've actually like invested in a
decent camera and a decent cameraman so
uh i'm trying to uh to to jump on all
that a little bit more you know i like
my problem is i like the quiet life too
much but i do yeah i gotta start putting
more more stuff out there for people
like a lot a lot of the british fans
sort of interact with me on online and
stuff but i know i gotta get myself out
there a little bit more so i am trying
you know i'm pushing myself ever so
slowly doing doing little bits more as
much as i can of course and what do you
stream on twitch do you play games
yeah yeah i just call of duty i'm like
really i'm pretty [ __ ] to be honest
i like it
it's a full-out disclaimer like don
if you're going to watch my twitch don't
expect to see any like savage savage
gameplay because i'm really bad i just
go on there for the for the crack and do
a big people and get her boobs pretty
much just
me my man's got nothing better than
doing the days between training but uh
we will have a good laugh if nothing
else you know yeah wait so the [ __ ] the
fight was in at o2 yeah
is that o2 arena
you know who's played there
sorry i'm just kidding
who should politicize me but
there's a little band in manchester just
a little band
i think uh when you're talking about
getting yourself out there more
just lead into the things that you like
like lean into the music and you love
mma like
mma fighters dissecting mma like there's
a market for that and you can build like
a
it that doesn't serve everybody but it
serves like the smaller audience that's
always going to be behind you like
you're an mma twitter favorite i don't
know hardcore people know you're that
good and i don't know people will people
know soon it's so clear when you watch
your fights because you
you do it everywhere you
you haven't been initiating wrestling as
much but you're like the best english
wrestler
i think i've ever seen straight up well
it's wrestling come on
well
i'm embarrassed i'm embarrassed that's
offense doesn't you know it's offensive
they
the best wrestler i've ever seen out of
the uk
that is so [ __ ] funny that's
hilarious
what i love about british people is when
they become fans of something they
[ __ ] go all out and stay die-hard
[ __ ] fans uh what what do you got
planned jack
can you tell us who you're gonna fight
just tell us
this is really for nick
we are like we haven't even talked to
the ufc yet i wanted a fight in june um
but i'm hearing like whispers that
they're going to be coming back to uk a
little bit later on in the summer so
obviously i prefer to roll out for a
card
it's always better like to have the
hometown crowd i say hometown crowd but
you know just fighting in london or
something like that is close to a fight
at home that i'm gonna guess so i'd much
prefer to wait plan like i think it's
about time i get like a ranked opponent
i thought i probably would have been in
the rankings after this one but um
yeah
give me one of the top dogs one of the
one of the guys that's going to get my
name out there more like
i called after fight ricky simone and
ascend selma is any of those guys is
going to push me to the top 15 like i
don't know what more gonna do i think
i've proved like there's not many guys
in my position that would have took a
fight with uh timothy valuev and um you
know my problem is i can't say no to her
to a fight going to anybody
it ego checks me when i get off for the
name i've gotta say yes so yeah i can't
do no more you know i think i've earned
it i've done it probably the hard way
there's been a lot of guys that have
like been rant they'll go rant in sports
and i've had a much easier route than i
have but you know that's the way i want
to do it coming from like um
like i've been in martial arts since i
was like six years of age and we would
always you you want to be the best and
fight the best of your competition so
i'm glad i've done it this way but you
know not now i think i've earned the
shot at those guys so i can finally get
a number next to my name and you know
forced to everyone i'm like top 15 in
the world that's uh something i wanted
to do for a long time
and you you said the like the only two
name well
the only other name on that
that would all like probably have to
agree to it because they're kind of on
the downslope is pedro munoz
uh which at nine but yeah
like any of them i mean like i know like
guys like obviously o'malley and dominic
cruz and frank yeager they're all
interesting names as well it's just
you know he's on the come up so he's
probably going to get a bigger name for
everyone you know frank frank he's out
bigger than him he's probably not going
to get chucked in against someone who's
not going to rank and you know so like
any of those four that i mentioned i'd
be confident to jump in with any of them
so
you know to be the best you've got
you've got to beat the best so whether
that's number 15 or or number one i i
should be prepared and i should be right
again with any of them and
i feel like i am so
fingers crossed you know sean shelby and
dana feel the same way and can uh and
give me a shot
hell yeah you [ __ ] dope
uh i would love to go to fights over
there they do it in london again
you so you i'll be like august you're
talking about
i've never been out of the country
yeah i think july or august we should we
went and take the king king and the
sting crew on tour and just could just
come to the uk watching oh that'd be
good oh that'd be fun
vlog where all we do is go around the uk
yeah that'd be interesting
[Music]
that'd be all the high needs it would
never happen yeah there
did you say it would never happen the
relapse at the oasis
that's
obvious i want to be coherent and i want
to be aware i want to look
i want to be just there you and jack
would be like paul rudd and jason siegel
at the rush concert and i love you man
i haven't seen i love you oh i love that
movie it's true uh what's your twitch
channel
uh jack show mma jack choi mma is again
disclaimer i'm not very good at all but
uh
we do we do we do have a laugh on here
and uh
you know it can get a little bit irate a
little bit abusive at times but i'm
pretty sure that's what people tune in
for anyway yes if you're not good you at
least gotta cause some controversy yeah
absolutely because if you're not good
you're going to start raging so
that's the route i'm gonna have to go
down
uh you should have uh cage warriors fly
you to san diego for some of their san
diego cards i want to go to one of those
that are outside they look dope and
they're super close and there's not
fighting in california very often
at least drivable yeah
i'm sure they've gone i think they just
announced another one now in um
in june because uh obviously my manager
grey i mean he runs the cage warriors um
he's like the ceo a cage warrior so he
is trying to get me out they he's got
like a little gym up here and he wants
me to come out so we got a media tour
for you if the if he gets you out here
we'll put you on stuff
yeah well
definitely like we'll get his fight date
sorted in as long as they don't crash
perhaps maybe not this one but the one
after i'll i'll i'll try and get out
i'll uh i'll see if i can get cage
warriors to fund it for me
some sort of employee
what did you uh how did you celebrate
you eat would you eat stuff or drink
stuff afterwards
the win
yeah so we we had like uh an after-party
box or um paddy and molly uh and myself
they were killing us meant to be
obviously
picked up a lot so he didn't come so it
was like a bunch of welsh and a bunch of
scousers or all sort of just crammed in
some into some little nightclub and uh
yeah it was good like
i don't think
they're like a
big british dj and all it was it was a
it was a bit of a wild night to be
honest the uh
you know we shot off early but i
allegedly the police came in and then
shut some shut some [ __ ] down towards
him
you know we managed to miss so loud
[Laughter]
that sounds that sounds amazing so i
to me in my head
you patty and meatball
and and jai it's like friends like the
the whole cast hangs out they're all
best but is it do you guys know each
other well is it like i know patty and
meatball are
yeah so like they're obviously very
close but i sort of come up on the same
the same circuit as um as molly and
paddy um for the cage warrior shows and
we've had the same manager so since like
party going to ufc we've we've become
really good friends to be honest and um
you know i only i say that i only have i
only see him at the [ __ ] fight weeks
like it's not like that oh i tell people
you're my best friend
like
them through a lot more friends than i
am with them but yeah we get on really
well and it's a good place it's got like
you know what their scouts is like they
just bring energy everywhere so it's
always good to have them fight week and
and in the change rooms beforehand so
yeah
it was a good atmosphere it was a good
week to be honest but uh they they just
they just like proper loose cannons
molly and finally they just see them
they just seem to bounce off each other
all the time like i'm more like fight
week i'm more like cutting weight trying
to like chill out and avoid everybody
and and i'm here just
well you've seen the videos party just
getting rid of everybody at the old time
that's it that's wild uh so what you
said jai didn't go out to the after
party would you go to an after party
after a loss that probably won't happen
for decades but not happening at all or
ever
yeah
what
[Laughter]
they said what would you do if you
didn't win kanye i guess we'll never
know
well jack thank you so much uh we'll
talk to you before the next one yeah
yeah
thanks for being on the show
anything else you want to say
no thanks for having me on you know i
always enjoy and chappelle i may see you
in june yes okay maybe i can make it
yeah we will link up damn that'd be so
cool
wow
he you'd have a sober buddy if he goes
yeah you don't have to you don't have to
that is true yeah no no no like that you
planted the seed now so i'm gonna have
to start looking for some tickets
you gotta you gotta start using the
muscle put it out on twitter you got you
got legions of fans jeff yep
oh and just like uh for no reason i'm
not going to use this information to
make money at all when you're fighting
do you try to knock someone out or you
try to submit them or the fight just
goes wherever it goes
again not related to anything personal
just curious if
just just out of curiosity i probably
just you've got you gotta flow with it
nick all right
you can't predict sorry dick
but
drop me a message before your next
[Laughter]
uh thank you jack thanks jackson thank
you congrats again bro congrats have a
good one
yeah
he's great that was awesome oh nick you
degenerate
[Laughter]
i bet i i bet him to win and then i bet
a little
by sub every time and
he just hasn't he hasn't been getting a
neck he did it on one maybe
the last one went to decision yeah yeah
yeah but he put like domination yeah
amazing fight too man
yeah domination
it it was like like it was kind of it
was kind of one one and then the third
round was back and forth but then he
just yeah dropped him
oh you saw it chin yeah it's not live
here i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding i love that there are
so many fighters with twitch channels
where they do nothing but game
i love that
i used to watch gameplay all the time
like for hours i do not play video games
i love watching people play video games
twitch is wild with like the amount of
hours the people who
our users of twitch put in like compared
to like a twitter instagram user like
people just have it on the background
all day yeah like i have a friend who uh
streams on twitch video games and she's
on there for like sometimes [ __ ] 12
hours just doing nothing but video games
did we get the name of his twitch yeah
come on
that was awesome i love jack
the magic mind we're awful
the weak about it oh god you got it
it'll slow you down but uh
god i i [ __ ]
i think with mma i just have like
literally i feel like i have an eye for
talent i watch these shitty shows
uh not the cage wars is like a shitty
show but like you see someone he's just
like that guy's [ __ ] real deal yeah
and then he was a fan of king and this
thing that's so dumb who was the one who
found out that he was a fan was it you
uh
yeah i think i actually think theo yeah
theo hit him up theo theo was like have
jack shore on he he follows me or
whatever and [ __ ]
uh yeah and he's like he watches it all
and he's an oasis fan yeah i remember
the day he told me i was like my face
lit up
ever since that moment you and nick just
like you guys have a euphoric glow about
you when you're talking to jack oh yeah
i love jack i love jax i have a problem
with but there's it's a weird
kind of like
sect of people that'll make me do it but
like i i'll fanboy out but like oh yeah
i love jack shore mm-hmm i thought who
else do you love [ __ ] listen are we
talking about fighting or just no this
is like this is like just [ __ ] i consume
like manifest it come on no no like
i met people from the yak which is the
sparstool daily show uh
i watch their show like in the
background most days they live stream 10
to 11 uh here and they had live shows
out for the super bowl
and we kind of like chat like we follow
each other and [ __ ] and i went up to him
and i like
fanboyed out kind of it was like i was
just like oh man i love what you guys do
like i i just felt like when someone
comes up to you and you're just the only
thing you can say is like yes thank you
yeah instead of having a conversation
and i felt like a douchebag
to be honest
it was it was too much
i like how you like sorry
slightly whispered that you know
christian was doing some good good
switching too i was looking at him and
then i think when you thought he wasn't
switching i'm sorry then no no
no we have to use it
no oh no we're leaving it in
and i think i come off like a dick to
you during the show but like you just
disappear like batman you're talking to
christian and then you
[Laughter]
just like bruce wayne's parents god
i hate that movie uh
i hate it i hate it hey you hated it
wait why did you hate it no that's fine
i quit no no i can't i can't work with
nick if he says that he hated the new
batman i liked robert pattinson as
batman but it was too dark and by like
literally just looking at it it was like
our the first episode cats after dark it
was two like the cinematography
was too dark the cinematography yeah not
necessarily the story yeah exactly i got
it i love
the joker but like i saw this meme it
was like the 1989 batman and then like
every batman and it just kept getting
darker darker and then 20 it had 2025
just a black
it's like screen
what is they're doing dark knight had
these moments i've said this on this is
like the third show i've said it on but
dark knight it was very dark but then it
had these moments where it showed gotham
during the day or when they were in
china oh okay it was just like super
bright and sunny and it like switched it
up
is that what he says
people say that it's the ethos of batman
i get it i don't give a [ __ ] it was too
dark and
i saw it at 4pm all right as long as as
long as that's your issue with it not
that the story wasn't good i didn't like
the writing like the dialogue there you
go
yeah
i was stood there like chris rock and
then continued on with the show yeah
like a professional
uh plugs plugs oh um
right
yeah i'll be in salt lake city salt lake
city please come hang out with me in
salt lake city uh send me also [ __ ]
send me some recommendations of what to
do out there last time i was out there i
rode a [ __ ] bike down a mountain i
don't want to do that again uh so now
i'll be there april 8th and april 9th at
wise guys comedy club then mace
what does it say
oh sorry yeah may 6th and 7th i'll be in
san diego california at a new comedy
club called mike drop comedy club which
i'm stoked about then i'll be doing a
one-nighter in the hometown of phoenix
may 12th that stand up live uh you
should if you've been going to stand up
live lately i think they got a little
billboard for me up there yeah
uh hometown love and then uh i'll be in
meatballs county
in [ __ ] uh june 25th and sorry june
24th june 24th or 25th i'll be in east
providence rhode island
jeez at the comedy connection you could
probably move the needle there
uh get people out yeah i'm i'm actually
going to go with chappelle back to rhode
island i don't you're not coming with me
but you can go okay perfectly we are
both going at it
hey if it sells if it helps me sell
tickets
meatball is going to be there
[Laughter]
i need to i need asses and seats
people good thing is is comedy
connection's small so it will be easy to
fill out oh really yeah what's the cap
i don't know like maybe like i think 56
i could be wrong 50 60
i mean like
during their cold [ __ ] 150 no no during
their coverage it was like max 50 60
people
there was yeah they were spreading 150
he said 50 i bet it's 150. oh
i bet it's 150. because every third
salt lake city we got a lot of seats to
fill please
guys like
look at me begging please like please
just
it doesn't say listen salt lake city if
i if i get listen
i'm bringing chin nick
i just want
this for all the knickers out there
i will not be in attendance i don't want
you to show up thinking i'm gonna be
there we'll be there we'll be there
i'm not going to lie with the uh
headphones on we might have to bleep
that out i hit it
i thought i heard it but i also
nick i'm looking out for you just in
case i'm looking out for you just in
case i don't make it home tonight i'm
not going to rhode island
he's not going to rhode island i was
talking too much i was talking about
salt lake
i say listen to it and see
lies
[Laughter]
no this one we're on tuesday i'm working
on it tonight yeah
yeah his next cat
uh yeah if you want to see me
onlyfans.comteen uh
follow jack shore on twitch at jackshore
mma if you want to watch him play video
games and get rowdy with his boys
don't go there why do you think no no
that's
meatball pulled up the page and says
sorry it's not available
there might be a underscore somewhere in
there yeah
i'm sure it's on his instagram bio or
something i'm going to try if i edit it
soon enough i want to add the car no
let's not do that
oh okay yeah you know well good luck
with that that's going to take a lot of
work i know yeah
i want to make this show good but i
don't then i run out of time and i'm
like oh and then so it's going to be
every friday friday yeah friday but
again they're hearing it friday friday
on friday thank you meatball
um
well before i do my plug uh
we were talking about books earlier i
think it'd be cool to give a book
remember book recommendation
you know what i was just thinking when
she said that uh that i don't really
actually know the jackson
the jack shore thing i give we should
give out a plug like something we want
some of the people to check out for
ourselves and then just a recommendation
of something okay that you're like
digging so like
you've been digging jack shore mma's
twitch watching twitch stuff video game
stuff
and if you want to give another one uh
another one i've been watching a lot of
viking content uh i just finished the
last kingdom fifth season very good
utrecht son of utred a bubba bag shout
out to him
parked
that's crazy we just named it episode
that but no it's that was a guy i do a
podcast with was it not yeah i could
hear his voice
um so real quick the books uh the game
by neil strauss i think it's not just
about picking up girls and stuff it's
honestly i love that book it's about
human psychology males females and all
stuff it's it's a really good book and
then um
the war of art
resistance you guys know what resistance
is later on it's oh it's a powerful
thing powerful powerful thing and also
the law of attraction was a pretty good
book too
wait is it the war of art or the art of
war the art of war is a book but the war
of art is about like people that are
created
that's why
uh
and youtube.com
shinsuy that's how you spell my name
shout out to brian johnson for this and
instagram.com chinsuji well how cool is
that how cool is that
nick
i really like the kanye documentary
if you're a fan of his music you see all
the stuff he rapped about as it happened
can't believe the guy was filming
i can't believe he caught all that yeah
it's like exactly how it's exactly how
kanye told the stories yeah like he's in
front of no id or yeah or joe from three
three aged capital oh i got the on the
left the last song yeah last call yeah
yeah when he tells the whole like story
of how yeah crazy
uh
yeah i think i captured last call
essentially and then below deck another
below deck podcast
uh check that out another podcast
network as well another podcast network
yeah it's all the same [ __ ] it's three
me and two buddies check it out yeah and
then just see pillow sticks on instagram
and it's about it
his tic talk is blowing up
mine
listen i was trying to help you out
[ __ ]
i don't post on it that much
anymore ever since you showed your balls
you're like man i [ __ ] this app
yeah i think the app is like man [ __ ]
him
for real they were like hey [ __ ] you
dude i'm showing your balls
this is for children i know all right
guys thanks for tuning in this week
thank you bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
so